a top economic priority is to ensure
that we can maintain a smooth and
efficient flow of goods and people from
the UK into the EU and vice-versa we
need to make sure that businesses are
ready for change circumstances and new
customs requirements now there are calls
some goods that require not just customs
checks but other procedures particularly
food and products of animal origin and
we've been working with Defra and the
relevant sectors in order to ensure that
those businesses are ready and also
taken very seriously our responsibility
to ensure that the rights of millions of
EU citizens in this country are
protected the government is absolutely
committed to the Good Friday Belfast
agreement absolutely determined to
ensure there will be no infrastructure
at the border and absolutely determined
to uphold the functioning of the
all-ireland economy that's why we will
have no checks at the border and no
tariffs until recently the EU has
maintained that the withdrawal agreement
was sacrosanct but now they have
acknowledged that it can be changed and
up until this point the European Union
have also said that the backstop was
inviolable but again European leaders
have said that they are not emotionally
attached to the backstop and there are
other ways other ways of ensuring that
we can safeguard the gains of the Good
Friday Belfast agreement and also ensure
that smooth trade flows across the
island of Ireland it's already the case
that under the EU settlement scheme more
than 1 million people have been granted
status and the Home Office is helping
thousands of new applicants every day
wait to see what Ireland and the EU
Commission will decide but we stand
ready to work with them to help
safeguard commerce and rights across the
island of Ireland now leaving the EU
without a deal certainly provides
economic challenges I do not shirk from
that but it also provides economic
opportunities this government is clear
we must honor that decision and that is
why I commend this statement to the